[Applause]
get it all for us
Zendaya's shocking fans with a surprise
performance at Coachella I'm sorry I
don't know what happened it was so cool
so so cool the actress crashed his
Labyrinth set on Saturday marking her
first live performance in seven years
to lab for inviting me and making all
this happen so last minute
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all for welcoming be back on
that stage
um
Open Arms it's been a very long time so
I appreciate it Zendaya totally Wows
Festival goers with two of her and
Labyrinth hits I'm tired
[Music]
[Applause]
and all for us from her HBO series
euphoria
foreign
[Music]
I have never heard screaming like that
in my entire life
as soon as I turn the corner
I couldn't hear anything I couldn't hear
anything but you guys I don't know what
I sounded like but I just was like you
know what I'm just gonna have fun it was
so special
and everybody was singing along yeah Z
fills the love after her long awaited
return to the stage and I just wanted to
say thank you again
for such a magical beautiful night
it's been a decade since the release of
Zendaya's self-titled album
[Applause]
and since she's been focused on her very
successful acting career I don't know I
think I've been through a lot
I don't know what to do with it I'm
definitely proud of of the work we've
all done and I'm and I'm proud of
um
you know
um how far all these characters have
come but just last year the 26 year old
revealed She'll always have a soft spot
for music when she released her first
track with Labyrinth which debuted in
euphoria's season two finale
[Music]
she tweeted I stepped away from music
quite a while ago for a number of
reasons but I still really love it
adding that the kindness and support for
just a little tiny toe dip back into
some music means the absolute world to
her there's a lot of emotions that are
attached to this I think because this
this show unlike anything else is so
personal that we have an entire crew of
people who dedicate every single day to
uh to making uh hopefully a beautiful
piece of art that resonates with people
for now fans can look forward to seeing
Zendaya and euphoria's season three
return next year but till then hopefully
there's more tunes and on stage Zendaya
moments to come
[Music]
[Applause]
oh